all right hello everybody welcome to my
session on analyzing source code using
roswell
um first of all let me start by
appreciating that you've all come to my
session
for some of you it might be very early
in the morning or very late in the
evening
but still you've taken time to join the
session of which i'm very grateful
so let's get cracked because we've got a
lot of stuff to
work with um my name is eric schweber
i work for exorcism i'm a.net foundation
member
and i love learning new languages so the
image that you see is a very apt
description of me
and it's also how i got to know exorcism
most of the talk will be done in live
coding
except for the first few slides which
give a little bit of a background
on what is the actual issue that i'm
trying to solve
so what is exorcism exorcism.io is a
website it's a free
and open source website with the aim of
helping
people improve fluency in a language so
if you're a c-sharp developer and you
want to become better in c-sharp
you can do that but if you want to learn
a new language there's also
a very uh plausible path to take on
exorcism and that is also how i got to
know it
the way that ectism goes about helping
you improve your fluency in a language
is by having tiny exercises which are
like small puzzles that you need to
solve
so the student downloads an exercise and
what gets downloaded is a test suite so
a set of tests
and the goal for the student is to
develop an implementation that passes
all the tests
the thing that sets exorcism apart from
other websites is that
once you're done and you have all the
tests passing you submit your solution
to the website
and then a code review is done by a
person that's familiar with the language
so there's an actual human being
reviewing your code so this human
interaction is great at improving your
skills in the length because
he can he or she can point out all the
finer details of the language
with the current version of exorcism
though there are some issues that we
have
the biggest issue that we have is that
sometimes there are so many more
students than there are mentors
um that it can take quite a while before
the student gets feedback on the
solution that was submitted
so that's obviously a pain point for us
another is that if 10 students submit
the exact same solution
it does require mentoring it 10 times
instead of being able to mentor it once
and then have to apply everywhere
and finally um is great for learning a
new language but
as ecosystem requires to to run things
locally on your machine
it means that you have to get everything
set up locally
like an sdk or possibly an ide so
there's quite a barrier for you to get
started
so that's also one issue that we have
all right um we've come up with some
solutions for that
and one is that many students will have
the same sort of
issues with their solutions
so mentors will recognize these parents
and say hey
this is a student that's using an if
statement but a switch would be more
idiomatic
so those are all rules that are in the
mentor's head but what we try to do is
encode those rules in code and the
analyzers
is a tool that takes a code that was
submitted by a student
and then looks for patterns and
automatically analyze it
similarly another thing that we try to
do is uh for the ten
identical solutions to come up with the
way that we only have to mentor them
once
and um they don't have to be identical
so if they're
identical except they're not identical
but they are just
different in white space for example or
the placing of their kerdi braces
um we could reuse the same comments so
we're trying to work
with the system to have that uh work
efficiently
and finally um as the students will be
able to do
in-browser coding they won't be able to
run the tests because
they won't run in browsing and we have
to have some way of executing them
on a server and there are some nice
things that we do there too
so um in this session we'll look at how
the c sharp track of hexazine
has implemented the aforementioned tools
and for all three tools
we've used roslan you probably know
russian as the name of the c-sharp
compiler
however rosen is far more than just the
c-sharp compiler
in fact rosin is the name of the net
compiler platform
and the thing that rossing gives us that
we are interested
is not the compiler but it's the parsing
of c-sharp source code
so russian gives us a way of taking
c-sharp source code
parsing it and it will then return a
syntax tree which is a
fully typed way of working with c chart
code
so we can parse the sharp code and then
work with it in c
sharp code a syntax tree contains up two
types of elements
the leaf nodes are syntax tokens and
tokens are just
a direct mapping to a little bit of text
in the source code for example
a keyword or a string on numeric literal
and tokens have possibly trivia
associated with them and trivia
are things that are ignored by the
compiler but they are
in the source but for example white
space and comments
the notes in the tree are syntax nodes
and they correspond to language
constructs for example
classes or namespaces so they are a bit
more high level
representation and their children will
be other notes or tokens
okay the best way to um to get
a bit of a grasp of what a syntax tree
is is to
either use visual studio which has a
very nice plugin that you can install
it's built in
and uh it allows us to give a visual
representation
of what a syntax free looks like so
i've opened visual studio here and if we
go to
view other windows and then to
syntax visualizer a window pops up
and if we click somewhere in the source
code it will populate this window with
the syntax tree
so this is the actual rostline syntax
tree that visual studio is using
underneath you can see that it has a
tree structure so there is a root node
in this case the compilation unit
and the compilation units children are
all the top level elements
and in this case there are two one is
the
using statement so if i click on this
using directive
it gets highlighted and the using
directive itself
contains sub nodes so there is a sub
node identify name
and it has a token using keyword
this is a token and it corresponds to
this bit of text
this specific token also has white space
trivia offered so it's trailing
and it's just a single white space so
you can see that
the tree representation is
a direct mapping of your c sharp source
code and each node will have
a class that's associated with it so the
using directive has
a type using directive syntax which is a
class that we can use later on
if you don't have visual studio for
example because you're working on a mac
or whatever
and you have another option it's
slightly less
fancy but still nice um and that is the
rustling quota which is a website made
by kyo osenkov
and on that website you can enter some
text just some c sharp source code and
click on
get rospin api calls to generate this
code
and then it gets a complete listing of
all the
different elements it's less pretty
um but it's functional and uh
it helps a lot instead of having to
drill through all the code
okay so now it's time for
the demo which will be the rest of the
talk and we'll be doing our demos in
writer
because that's my preferred ide and also
to show that you don't have to do these
things in visual studio
so let's switch to writer
first tool that we will be building is
the analyzer and the analyzer
is the tool that encodes the rules that
the mentor had in his head
or her head so it's just a regular.net
core tool
so nothing fancy there and and
the student has worked on an exercise
and that exercise contains of two
bits of code so there are the tests
and there are only two because the
functionality that the student is
expected to
implement is a greeting method that can
be called either
without any parameters in which case
hello you
exclamation mark is returned or it can
be called with
a name parameter in which case hello
name
exclamation mark is returned so very
simple
the solution that the student came up
with and submitted
is this one um it uses method
overloading
and a little bit of string concatenation
so it looks okay
um but let's see if we can build a
little bit of
logic in our analyzer to guide the
student towards a
somewhat more concise and hopefully more
idiomatic solution
so to do so i've stepped two things
already which
one is the the path to the file of the
student
the exercise file and the other is
reading that file into a string
so the first thing that we need to do is
well we want to use
rosland's c-sharp parsing functionality
so we need to install a nuget package
and the package that we need to install
is microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp
so let's install that into our
local project great and then we are
we are ready to parse c sharp source
code so the way that you do that is you
do c star c sharp syntax tree
dot parse text and then you can parse it
yeah there are many overloads but for
now we'll just parse the text that we
just
uh that we had already stopped and this
will return
a syntax tree so we'll call that tree
the tree itself is nice and it has lots
of properties
but we are mostly interested in the
three nodes because the three nodes
contain the actual source code structure
so there's one thing that we also need
to do which is
to get at the root
so we'll call that root and let's
debug this and see what the root is
right one two three
here we go so let's go over this one
and we can see here that the root is of
type completion unit syntax
and as you might recall that's the exact
same note that we saw
in the visual studio in syntax visual
life
so that's nice we now have access to the
c-sharp source code
we won't go into all the properties but
we'll be discovering them while we're
developing the analyzers
so what should we have as a rule so
one thing that i don't like about this
is that it uses method overloading
whereas it could be using a default
parameter
so let's try and build an analyzer for
that
so if it uses method overloading and
then we'll pass in the root
we'll write out please use an
optional parameter instead of
method overloaded let's remove the
step and create the method
all right so we have the root so
how do we detect if method overloading
is used
at this point it's usually good to have
a real firm grasp in your head
of what the syntax looks like in the
tree so one thing that we can do is we
can parse this code
put it here and then we can see
that it's a method declaration uh
and the type of the method declaration
is method declaration syntax
all right and we can use that so the way
that we do that
is that we can ask the route for all of
its children
so all of its nodes and then we can
filter those nodes on
a type so in this case uh it's a method
declaration syntax
so the result of this will be all the
children that are of this specific type
and then we can
do a count of all the methods
where the identifier and the identifier
is the
bit of the tree that describes the name
it has a text property
and this is just the method name so this
will return all the number of
the count of the number of methods where
the name is equal to greeting
if that is greater than one um
method overloading must be used so
if we run this again we should get a
comment
that the student uses method overloading
but that
an optional parameter can be used and
indeed that's what we see here
so we gotta first analyze him relatively
quick
at this point the student will get a
message that there was a comment from a
mentor
or from an automated analyzer and
usually the student then fixes the issue
so
the way this this student decided to fix
it is by
making the name parameter optional and
adding the null
as the default value and then adding
this
check so this becomes like
this and student moved this
to here and this removes the
method overloading bit so running it
again would not trigger the method again
the message all right nice
so the second thing that i would suggest
uh to the student here
is that instead of using no the default
value is actually
you so it's a string lateral that you
can use so
if users know as default
value let's output another message
please use a string
literal as the default value
and let's see how we can detect that
um we know at this point i could be
doing a return here but
i want for just for gravity that
the method has a greeting method because
we are guaranteed that before this
analyzer runs
all the tests are passing so we can make
some assumptions there
and the beginning is thus very similar
we'll look for the greeting method so
once again we find all the methods and
then we find
the one method which name
oops method.identifier.text
equals greeting so this finds the one
method
declaration that has the name greeting
so let's call this greeting method
and as i said we are interested in
looking at the
default value so what we can do is we
can go back to the
syntax visualizer but we can also start
by just looking at the properties of the
class and there are lots of things here
and some of them you will probably
recognize like body
um or expression but there's also a
parameter list
and we are we're interested in
parameters so let's look into that
property it itself has um
the opening in the closing parenthesis
but it also has parameters
and we can do get access by them by
index so this is the first parameter
and then what's there hey there's a
default and this of type equals value
clause syntax oh
now things are getting a little bit
complex so what we
sorry what we can do is we can parse
this
back here and see what
the representation is of the name equals
null bit
so we have a parameter this is the
equals failure clause
hey and this is a null literal
expression this looks like the thing
that we're looking for
um it's type is a literal expression
syntax
so what this means is you don't just
have no literal
expressions you can also have string
literal expression etc
and they are described by the same
clause the way that you can
differentiate between them is by
looking at their kind and the kind is
just a big enum with all the different
options
so we have to find check if it's a
literal expression syntax
where the kind is a null literal
expression
so let's do that we can go back
so we can do if
the default is a literal
expression syntax and we'll assign it to
the value literal
and the literals kind
is equal to syntax kind
dot no literal expression
then it must be using as its parameters
default value
sorry dot value
and no literal expression so if we run
this the second
case should hit it so let's see that
all right please use a string literal as
a default value
all right we're being a good citizen
again and we'll just do
this and already the student is really
happy because it's starting to look very
nice and concise
and usually my next point would be to
look into
using string interpolation because i
personally really like it and i think it
makes it a little bit more concise
um if does not use
string interpolation
please use string interpolation
to format the return string
all right
we'll do a little bit of copy pasting
here uh we won't do any
refactoring or whatever we can do later
if we would like that and we'll grab the
same method reference
and now what we want is to see if any of
the
we can we can make this as fancy as we
would like but we'll do it very simple
check
we'll just check any of its descended
nodes or any of its the children of the
method
so any of its statements um
is of type and then we have to find out
the type we could go back to
the syntax visualizer or to the russell
encoder
but you can also just try what if i just
do interpolated o there are several um
you can try
you can just also debug and see what the
descendant notes are
in this case i know it's a interpolated
string expression syntax
it's a long name and if there aren't
if there are not any so this method
returns true if there aren't
any uh notes in the tree
in the tree of the greeting method which
itself is subtree
and that have the type interpolated
string it will return true
so if we run this it won't detect any of
the
string interpolation types because there
aren't any and it will return the
message
so fixing this we can do it really
easily because there is built-in
conversion um like this
and this fixes the issue
yep and oh
and i say oh i did the wrong thing sorry
there
i meant to do this so there was a little
spoiler for the next session
all right
and it works so i you probably have
guessed the final thing that i would
like to detect is
using an expression body because i
really like that it's a single line
method
um not everybody likes them if
you can use expression body so i'll have
to be
i'll be a little bit gentle in my
message so consider
using an expression body
this is i found that people get really
religious about this so
um i'll try and make it a suggestion
more than the rest so let's copy paste
this again
and then we can just drill into the
properties again and see what it looks
like
so tons of properties here um the thing
that we are interested in is
either a body or an expression body
and the way that the wrestling works is
that a method can have either curly
braces and then the body is set
an expression body is null or it can be
an expression body and
expression body is said and body is now
so in this case
what we want to check if the body is not
known
so it has a body and if you might recall
expression bodies only are allowed when
there is a single statement so let's see
what we can do there and um
the thing that i'm trying to get across
is that just by dotting into the
the classes and the instance of the
class you are probably
really getting along with uh
with the tree so the there is a
statements list
and we can just do if the count
equals one
and this speaks to how well designed
rosman is because
i find this relatively intuitive
body.statement.com
this almost reads like pros so
let's run it it's also good that it's
very nicely designed because the
documentation can sometimes be a little
bit lagging
and now let's use this refactoring and
run it again
and we shouldn't have any comments all
right
so um with relatively little code
um there's a lot of duplication here
that we could eliminate
we were able to guide the students from
a solution that used
10-ish 12-ish lines to a single line
solution that
i think is really pretty and concise and
we can apply this to more
complex scenarios too but for this case
something relatively easy would also be
very helpful to us
and that mentors wouldn't have to
comment on them again
so this is the first tool and that we've
done so i'm gonna unload this project
and move on to the next one and the next
tool
is the representer and the goal of the
representer is to take a student's
solution
and to somehow create a representation
of it
that and we can then look at the
representation
to compare solutions so if 10 solutions
that are identical
they should have the identical
representation and if 10 solutions are
almost identical for example they're
only different in white space
they should still have the same
representation and this will allow us to
comment on the representation once and
then have it applied to
all the solutions so this is a big win
for us
the way this exercise works is it's
slightly different it's a test about
a leap year and we're not really
interested in the test now so
let's just open the solution that the
students submitted
so this is the solution it's a
completely working solution it
passes all the tests and only the
formatting is
a bit inconsistent so there are two
spaces here there are lots of empty
lines here
the curly brace is on the same line here
the opening and the opening is on the
new line here
so lots of things here that if we didn't
do anything about the code will
mean that they won't be equal so
the representative is very
similar to the analyzer at its core so
we have the same
package reference and it's also just a
console application
and i've stopped out a little bit and
it's the same basically as the previous
one where i read the
the contents of the implementation file
so that's
the exercise and i parse
it to a tree and get it root so we have
the root here
and the next step we have is to somehow
write
this to a representation a
representation you can think of also as
a hash
so i have a path representation is a
single file
and we'll just name it
representation.txt so how do we
uh put our root into the file
well as it turns out rosslyn has a
really interesting and nice feature
where it not only allows you to parse
c-sharp source code to
an in-memory representation of that but
it can also convert back to source code
so any node you have in your tree you
can convert back to c-sharp
source code not every compiler does this
but rosin does and that's really
nice and i can show you how it works by
doing file.right alt text representation
file so we'll write into the file and it
will be
here in a minute and then what we can do
is we have the root node and the root
node is a syntax node
of type compilation unit syntax although
we don't care about that
and if we do to string it's basically a
back and forth so we're now
parsing it to rosin's representation and
back to source code
and if we run this application we should
be seeing a representation created here
and we do and you are probably not
surprised that if i open this
it is the exact same contents
except for the ide hints as the source
because we didn't do anything
but this in itself is already really
useful and this is also why
roslyn stores the trivia the white space
etc
because many syntax trees for other
languages don't include the trivia
and that means that you can't go back to
where you're from because you're losing
knowledge
so um let's try and fix some things
about the representation
try and normalize it so the first thing
that i would like to do is
because i'm ocd i would really like to
normalize everything
so white space usage etc placing of
curly braces
and you might be thinking that this
could be the rest of the talk
but you've been mistaken because it's
just a single method
any syntax node you can call normalize
white space and let's just run it and
see what it does to our representation
isn't that great
so with just a single method called
roslyn was able to
normalize the code according to its
built-in standards coding styles
so already it's looking much better
and the next thing that i would like to
remove from the representation is the
using statements
students could use could have opened
using statements that are unused etc
and normally we are not in the habit of
commenting on using statements
and we already know that solution passes
the test so it's
all good let's just remove them from the
representation
how would we go about doing it um well
what we can do is there is a property on
the root
that's called remove nodes and then we
pass in
a an innumerable node so
we can reuse what we just learned about
having a descended nodes property
and then filtering by type and the type
of
using statement let's just do a quick
let's put this here whoops sorry
so let's put this here save it and then
dig into this a little bit so we can see
that it's a using directive and the
class is using directed syntax
okay so going back it has the type
using directive syntax and then we have
to supply a second parameter and there
are many options here
which i won't bother you with but let's
just do the first one because it works
well
and let's run it and see what happens to
our representation
oh nothing happened so why is that
this is actually expected so one really
interesting property of rosin is that
it's completely immutable
the whole tree every note is immutable
which means that once a
tree is created it can never mutate it's
immutable you cannot change things
except by creating a new tree with
modifications
so removing the nodes did remove nodes
but it didn't remove them in the source
it actually returned a new tree so
if we call the new tree representation
and then use that
to write out our code again then we
shall be seeing results
so this is a very important property uh
in roslin that you should really be
aware of
you cannot just mutate a bit of the tree
you have to create
a new instance of the tree and the
reason for this
is um for concurrency issues mostly
because if everything's immutable you
don't have logging because you can't
have multiple threads
accessing the same notes at the same
time which makes it great for the ide
itself because it will be doing in
things in the background
etc so it's really
it's a tough to implement you have to be
very diligent about it
but the end result is something that's
really nice i mean the performance is
also still
good so um something that's immutable
doesn't have to be
bad performing but it's something that
you always have to keep in mind when
working with roslin and syntax trees
they are immutable all right
so while this works um there is a nicer
way to do
these uh i want to modify some parts of
the syntax tree
functionality so the way that you can
also do this
is by having a class and we'll call it
remove usings
and have it inherit from c-sharp syntax
rewriter
so the idea of the c-sharp syntax
rewriter is
that for every type of node or token
that you have in the tree
you have a method that you can override
and you can basically
say hey i want to do something special
with this node.token
and the c syntax rewriter will
automatically
visit the tree in the right order etc it
will do all sorts of things
from you and will return the correct
tree
so th this example we can rewrite as
follows
so we start with overriding that's
always the case with the c sharp syntax
rewriter
and then it's visit and then it's the
type of the syntax node
now we were using a using directive
so we'll overwrite this method and
instead of doing
just the built-in functionality we can
return
no and you can see that the syntax node
is nullable
so if we do
new remove using
and then you do visit so you can call uh
tons of methods if you have a specific
node but we now have the root node which
is just of type
syntax node so if we pass in the root
here
we get back uh a new root node
with the updated representation so let's
run this again
and it should still remove the using
and it works that's nice and personally
i really like this feature
um it's a little bit more chord now but
if you try to do more complex
things this method really shines and
let's try to do some more
and we'll use this method for the rest
of the the case
um one obvious thing to remove are the
comments so we have xml documentation
code
we have multi-line comments and single
line comments
so let's do
class remove comments
and also have it inherit from the syntax
rewriter and
if you remember from the slides
uh comments are things that are not
compiled so they're only there in the
source code but not for
compilation purposes and everything
that's not for compilation purposes
like white space and comments is named
trivia
so what we can do is we can overwrite
visit
trivia and we can't just return no
because
well for two cases for two reasons
syntax trivia is a struct
so we can't return now and if it was uh
we would also be removing all of the
white space
which i don't want i'll just want to
remove the
syntax of the comments so what we can do
is
trivia dot is kind this is a syntax
uh token and they also have the kind
property
that we saw before so we can do syntax
kind and then
we can just do comments and we find
several things
um let's try single line comment trivia
and if that is the case well we can't
return null but we
can return just default and here we can
do base dots
visit trivia and this will just do the
regular
uh functionality we only have a special
case for the single line comments
so we'll just duplicate this line
add the call to the remove methods
rewrite it
run it again and we should be seeing
that this single line comment is removed
and like that it's gone so adding the
others
is very simple and
you've probably already guessed parts of
it so
this is a multi-line comment trivia
and there is also um
sing online documentation comment trivia
so it's quite for both but it does
specify well
what it's doing so run it again
and we'll get rid of all the comments
all right very nice um another thing
that
struck me when i looked at this code was
that some of the variables are defined
using
the var keyword and others just by the
type
so um what we can do is we can just use
var everywhere so let's try that
i'm a huge far fan too so that suits my
purposes use var as type
in this case it might be useful to see
what is the
syntax for variables oh sorry that was
the wrong
and we'll go here and we'll click on the
bool
and examine what its tree looks like so
bull is part of the variable declaration
and the variable declaration is of type
variable declaration syntax all right so
we can work with that
and the difference between a bull the
fire declaration of var is
that in for avar the type is an
identifier name
and identify name is just a bit of
string in this case so far
so let's see if we can work with that
go back to our rewriting overrides
variable declaration and then
we'll look at the node dot
and type so you might be thinking
hey let's do node.type equals and then
do something
so we can do that because well roslyn is
immutable so there is no way to
set a property on the node so for
everything that you
can modify roslyn has withers
so there are methods that starting with
width and then
the property that you can modify so
there is a way that we can
change the node and have it use a
different type
all right so we can pass in a type
syntax there um
you might be thinking
oh sorry
[Music]
so you might be thinking how can we
create that
um and it's actually not done by
just doing this just moving up
things so what you do is there is a
syntax factory and the syntax factory is
just a static class with
many many many uh properties and there
are
types everywhere so
let's just for to see what it looks like
do a little debugging
just to give you an idea of what all the
properties are
so variable declaration syntax and you
can see here
that the the two string method also
works on individual notes
so this is a nice way of declaring the
boolean
and there are many many properties and
we can see here that there is the type
which is the predefined type syntax and
if we continue
the type is oops
where is the type yeah the type is here
and now it's identifier name syntax
so that's the one we want so the type
should be identifier name syntax
so with type syntax factory
dot a name and then we can just
pass in the string so just to make it
very clear
what's happening this is a new
variable declaration type so
we basically create a copy of the
existing one and then have one property
modified
in this case the type property is
modified to the
identifier name and if we now run this
we should be changing our boolean
variable to avar
all right so i guess i
right oh i have a slight mistake here
let's fix that my bad
easy fix and now
the comments should be moving the virus
all right yeah so this is nice
um let's look at another thing that we
can do
this if statement uses curly braces
and this statement doesn't so
functionality wise there is no
difference
but syntax wise it will result in two
different representations for us if we
just upload this so let's add
a add curly braces if there aren't any
so we're doing that with another
rewriter and
if add braces
to if for else
statements make a c-sharp syntax
rewriter
and well let's just do
visit if and there are just a couple of
matches so usually this is just enough
to
figure out where you got to go and then
let's see what we can do so if we go
back to
visual studio and we'll look at what the
format is of this
if statement so this is an if statement
and it has a block
and if we go back here we can see that
the block itself is the bit between
curly braces and if we go to here
we can see it doesn't have a block it's
just directly a return statement
so we check for the node
and if you don't know which property you
can also do with
just to get a grasp of the things that
you can change
and in this case it's not the condition
because that's the boolean part
it is the statement so if the statement
is a block syntax
that means it's an if statement that
already has the curly braces
we can just continue in the other case
it doesn't have block statements so how
can we add those
well we can modify it directly so we
have to use one of the width methods
we can do with statement and
the we want to basically wrap the
existing statement in a block so we do
syntax factory dot
block and the block can take any
statement so we can pass the
existing nodes statement so we're
basically wrapping the existing
statement
in a block and then using that as the
statement for the new node
and let's see what that looks like
and we should be seeing something here
and now it has braces so you can see
very little code
for things that might look complex um
let's do the else just to
get it out of the way and to show you
that
russian is really well designed and it
has lots of symmetry where you expect it
to be
so we can we use the exact same code and
russian doesn't go overboard with
inheritance so many things that you
might think are inheriting from each
other aren't
which is a good a good thing i uh i feel
so in this case the else clause doesn't
have anything to do with the if step
except for
some very higher base class
and you just have to do a bit of code of
copying but that works
nicely i think
all right and the else is added to
so let me be very quick for the last one
so one obvious thing that we found that
students do is change variable names or
parameter names
so if we supply them with the gear
parameter they might rename it
but renaming the parameter doesn't have
any influence on the actual
representation because this was the
exact same code
except for the name so let's see if we
can normalize that
normalize identifiers
and this time we need a little bit of
state so what we want is that each time
we have
a parameter definition um we have to do
something with it so let's start with
overriding the visit parameter method a
parameter has an identifier line
property which is the name of the
parameter and that has a text property
so let's keep track of
the there's a dictionary of string of
string
that maps the old identifier so the
original parameter name
and maps it to a normalized one
called this mapping dictionary
so we can do mapping dot try add
and then copy in the original
name of the parameter and then as the
new value we can do something like
identifier and just well make it easy
and do the number of
existing ones in it and then
we can this doesn't really do anything
except keep track of it
and so we want to modify the parameter
itself too so we can do nodes
with identify and then do syntax factory
dot identifying name and then passing oh
this is not identifying name this is an
identifier
and then we have to do mapping
so basically what we're getting here is
the new
version of the parameter name the
normalized one which is equal to this
so if we run this and we have to add it
here
let's see what the representation does
and it has changed the parameter
um well this doesn't really do much
except uh
now we didn't change the actual usage of
the parameter so we have to change that
too
and the way we can do that is by
overwriting anytime a an identifier is
found visit identify name
so we can then do mapping dot
try get value to see if there is
a map identifier for this identifier's
name
and if there is we can i'll put it in
the map identifier
property and return
node dot with identifier
and do syntax recreate identify a name
map property same mistake sorry
so this is now the ordering is really
important because the parameter is
visited first
and um this parameter has a
an identifier in it so it's really
important that the
c-sharp syntax rewrite first calls visit
parameter and then calls
visit identify name which it all handles
for us and
that being built in i don't have to do
anything with it
so let's run it
all right and that's now completely uh
makes the
normalized identify the one that's used
inside the method and
it would be trivial to add it to uh the
class decoration and whatever
so uh but i'm running out of time a
little bit so
let's just do that later if somebody
would like to see that
and let's move on to the last one the
last two
so that is the test runner the test
runner has
two projects
it has the test runner itself and it has
a student solution the student solution
is the same as
the previous one just as a lot of tests
and an implementation that passes the
test which is admittedly much nicer than
the previous one
i'm going to unload this project and i'm
going to remove
its bin object directories because
writer will have done some magic in the
background already
and we don't want that and i'll show you
later why
so the test runner um it will be
different from the previous tools
because now we will be working
with a project because we want to run
all the tests that are in a project
and the goal of the test runner is to
take a student's solution and have it
run against the test suite
and then detect if there are failing or
passing tests
and for the failing and the passing test
write out the json report
so we could have done dotnet testing
parsing the
the text output but i don't like parsing
text output because it's
well brittle and um just
because it might be cool to do something
like in-memory stuff
i wanted to try and do this all with
some nuget packages instead of doing
just shelling out to the cli
so the first thing that we need is we
need some new
packages so what we need is instead of
using microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp
we need micro.codens.cshar.workspaces
and this bit is required
to be able to work with cs approach
files
um it's not enough though um because we
also need the
ms build code investor.workspace.msbuild
package and the combination of those two
will allow us to work with cs approach
files
so let's get started first thing to do
we
i have a reference to the exercises
project file
and we have to create a workspace and a
workspace is
like an environment where you can
keep track of your solutions and your
projects etc
so when you're working with projects and
solutions you always create a workspace
first
the workspace has a method that's called
open project async
and we can pass it a path to a project
file so i have that already stopped out
and we can then await it and this will
be a project representation so this is
an in-memory representation
of what the project file looks like
let's just run this and see what
happens
it does compile so that's good whoops um
we got an
exception could not load file or
assembly microsoft.build
um the thing here is that when working
with the imagebuild workspace
nuka package it will under the hood use
ms build
and for different versions of the net
framework on tournament or
um there will be in different os's there
will be different places where ms build
is located
so there is a package that you can use
um it's called microsoft dot
build.locator
let's install it and its sole purpose
is to somehow make it known where ms
build is located
so you do miss build locator dot
register defaults
you have to make sure that you call that
before the first call to
an ms build api method and um
let's run it and debug it to see if it
now works
and indeed we now don't have an error so
hooray
let's see what the project looks like so
there are many many properties here
um one of them that's important to us is
documents
so it contains all the files that are in
the project in this case we have two
a test file and an implementation file
so
let's stop that we'll remove this
message
next step is how do we run x unit in
memory
for that we need another two packages
the first one is just a regular
x unit package so let's install that
and the second one that we need is
something that's called
an x unit terms a runner is found in
xunit.runner.utility
and the runner is something that is able
to run the tests
so let's install those
and then we have access to a
type that's called the assembly runner
[Music]
so one thing that we can do
is the assembly runner uh sorry i
get the wrong so assembly runner we have
to create it like this sorry
it has to be passed in an assembly file
and we don't yet have an assembly
we do have a project though and projects
can be compiled to assembly so
how do we get from a project to an
assembly
to do that the first thing that you need
to do is you have to get
the project's compilation so our
compilation equals compilation acing
and a compilation is an in-memory
representation
of well an assembly or something that
you can compile
it isn't compiled yet it's just in a
representation
and when working with compilation the
first thing that you should always do is
check its diagnostics
so the diagnostics are the things that
you will be seeing if you do rebuild
warnings errors etc so let's
do a little bit digging on to see if
there are any errors
so diet.severity equals
error and this will be
errors so the first thing i
did is get the diagnosis and then i
filtered them where the severity is
error
and let's output the number of errors
and see if everything works well here is
dot
count let's run it
and let's see if that's working nicely
oops 123 errors
ouch so one thing that we can do
is see just what the errors are because
well
we have an in-memory representation of
those so errors
let's see what they are
a little bit of waiting and
whoa predefined type system object is
not defined or
imported um how can we fix that and what
is the issue here
well the issue is actually that um we
didn't do a dotnet restore
and dotnet restore has some properties
that it creates a
file that contains all the assemblies
that need to be loaded
and um this is also why i unloaded the
project because if i didn't do it
writer would have done it in the
background so um one thing to do to fix
that is to do
process dot start and we'll just shell
out to the.net
cli here
[Music]
and we do dotnet restore and then use
the project file path
so this will do a restore in the
background and we'll wait for it to exit
run it again see how many errors we have
hopefully less
and no we we actually have more how is
that possible
so um it turns out that this is actually
a bug that i found out last week
um and the thing is that you are that we
are missing
an assembly reference and the assembly
web is not automatically added
but we can add it manually it's called
nuget.project model
and if we install that into our project
and then run it again we should be
having a errorless compilation
fingers crossed all right
so now what we did is actually we are
sorting doing dot net build
in memory we still aren't there what we
want to be
because the assembly runner needs an
assembly file name
so how can we have a compilation output
and assembly file
and that's actually very easy there is
an emit method
and that emit method takes lots of
overloads and but one of them is just
the file path
and we could hard code it just run a.dll
or whatever
but there is also a nice property
compilation.sourcemodule.name
that contains the dll name as the
project would be
output so this will output the dll to
this
location and then we can open we can
create this
assembly runner so now
we're almost ready to really run the
test so let's see what the assembly
runner has
for its properties um it has tons of
callbacks actions and the thing that we
are
interested in is whether the test is
passing or failing
so we can do a little
console logging here and we'll just do
this is a failing test
and then output the test display name so
you can see here
that the properties of the the info
callback parameter
are matching them of the domain of x
units so
this is really an x unit internal
specification so let's use that and
just to have us be complete
also add callbacks for the other two
possible statuses that x-unit supports
which are
skipping and passing tests
and then finally let's see if we can run
the assembly runner
not array segment and there is a method
and the method is called start alright
so let's run this and see what it does
no errors good but there is also no
output
so this is weird um it took me a little
time
but if you go to the documentation of
start
it says this call returns immediately so
it doesn't wait for the test to finish
there is a callback on execution
completed
so but what can we do here
um the excellent documentation suggests
using
what's called the manual reset events
link
and you can sort of see this as a flag
so
we call this finished and when it starts
it has a flag down so you can actually
do you can't pass it
but you have a method that goes that
makes the flag go up
and if you do finish dot wait
it will wait for the flag to go up and
initially it won't be
um once the execution is complete and we
get here
we can just set the flag and it will go
up and
this blocking call will then continue so
let's run it again
all right it doesn't work and it doesn't
work because
there are there is an issue with loading
the assembly
and the way this is working is that as
xunit will try to look for the assembly
in the current
assembly load context and our
dynamically compiled executable isn't in
that
and the fix is relatively easy we can
load the assembly
and just use this name
and then run it again
let's do it very quickly because i'm
running out of time
and all right it now actually run all
the tests in memory and we've got our
calling callbacks called so it does say
skip a lot
and that's because our tests are except
for the first one
all marked with skip and um
this is because we want to encourage tdd
where students solve
a bit of the implementation one at a
time and
let's see if we can fix that because we
now have syntax
the test runner syntax and we can do
something with it
first let's grab hold of
project dot documents so these are all
the documents that are in the project
and we do a single drop down name equals
test runner exercise success dot cs
so this is our document
and um for that sorry
for the document we can get its syntax
rootness
this is a different way of getting the
center root instead of calling the parse
method
so we now have the root of the test and
we can just write a syntax rewriter that
we just did
so unskipped says i'm going to make this
a bit quick because i'm running out of
time
we'll override the visit attribute
because we are interested in the
fact attribute we can check that by
doing node.name.
to string equals
fact and
we can then do we have to modify the
node so we can do a wither
and we can say that this argument list
we don't want any arguments so we're
effectively removing
the skip bit and then we can apply that
to our route
so this is root
we'll just reassign it for the moment
this doesn't do anything yet because
remember everything is immutable
so this will return a new root and the
document won't be updated
but what we can do is we can do
document. with
syntax root and again not only the
syntax trees are immutable the documents
are two
so let's reassign the document and to
make things even
stress it a little bit more and this
won't work actually
so let's run it and see that this
doesn't do anything
except for running the test as it did
previously and
already explain why because the
document.with syntax would return
not only a new document but it also
returned a new project
so um everything is immutable including
the project and the fix is easy
we'll just reference the project from
the document
and now we run it
it should all work
and now it's all passing so we used
rosslyn to
get everything working and we did a
little bit of the syntax rewriting etc
i have a different version where i don't
write to an assembly but it's
it's relatively involved so i didn't
have any time to incorporate this into
the slide but it will be in the source
code
so that's the demo i want to thank you
all for coming i
really enjoyed doing this and the slides
are all up the source codes too
if you like exorcism go to the website
xsin.io
if you want to help us build these kinds
of tooling or for other languages
go to github.com v3
and i don't know if we have any time for
a question because it's quite late
but uh if not uh thank you very much and
hope to see you again
a different time hi eric
so let me put on my earplugs i'm sorry
all right do you hear me
yeah i can hear you i think it's a lot
of questions on the slack channel
so you might want to scoot over there
and answer people
all right um you kind of have a five
minutes
five seven minutes all right yeah so if
you
are able to answer those questions by
then
oh yeah all right um i'm seeing some
message
about uh using linkpad for syntax
visualizing
and which is really helpful and linkpad
is a really nice tool
so thanks for that richard um
can we get the hands on the source code
yeah so um
i'll post it in the in the reply soon
so um that source code will have a
master branch that contains all the
the source that i just built uh it also
contains an
initial branch if you want to build it
all yourself let's see if you can work
it out yourselves
and there isn't something with x unit
that does everything completely in
memory if you like that
um guillermo ferreira as if ms build
workspace is available on a non-winner's
runtime
and it is and this used to be a real
issue it used to even
not be possible to do this on.net core
um
it was tied to dotnet framework but over
the last year or so
it has been made fully open source so uh
i actually develop
most of this tooling on my mac machine
so yes it is fully non-windows supported
source will be great we'll be doing
if you try to run tests in memory
loading the assembly to
assembly load contacts yes i tried to do
that and you can definitely do that
but it was a little bit much for to do
this in this presentation
or if it's asked the example that used
if an else statement
would help if statements being nested
no i don't think so um i'm not sure if i
completely understand what's saying but
we can go into that later perhaps um
thomas
thank you for the compliments also call
for the source code
yeah definitely everything that i do is
open source so i'll put it up for you
um status says i can't think of anything
i can use this for but it was really
cool
i'll take it as a huge compliment we're
all programmers so
it's just fun to play with this and i
started playing with this before it's
actually
thought of a use case so maybe getting
started with this
then leads to possible use cases later
on
cyrus says things that was useful okay
thank you very much justin says the same
oh somebody has already found the the
link to the source code
so yeah if you want to find me on the
interwebs i'm always
named the same just extreme just my name
my twitter my linkedin my get up
it's really easy thanks for the
possibility with roslyn
my pleasure my pleasure everybody's
doing
lots of things that i really enjoy
seeing everybody's really happy
cool presentation interested in topping
all right
brilliant um let me see there's also
some in the chat
somebody says there are checkered parts
in the window probably to hiding
something
oh sorry using our bacteria correct it
was a little bit of a coding mistake for
myself
are else if statements are separate type
of will it be braced
uh they are separate type elses and ifs
so um that was one of the points that i
tried to make is that
you might be thinking that it would be
an if statement
but it's actually an if statement that
has an else clause
and the else clause is a different type
again so um
almost every little bit of syntax that
you have has a special dedicated class
for them and all right simone says great
work at exorcism and with this
presentation thank you
some people are talking so just just
wait
um i think yeah i can
grab a link to the source code in
between
and oops let's move this here
[Music]
github
so i'll just post it again just to make
sure that everybody
all right thank you guyana uh it's great
to see so many people show up
i was a little bit anxious that people
might think brosnan
that's just the compiler how can be ever
be interesting
but apparently people found it
interesting so great to hear
all right you're welcome
i'm not sure if i pronounced that
correctly but well i'm just dutch so
all right i don't see anybody typing
again
oh uh a dutch donkey bell
and that was for us duchy sorry for the
rest
just saying thank you in dutch